well I hope you enjoyed the last Parts
material because there's a whole bunch
more where that came from here today as
this is the finale to a video series my
team and I have been working on for many
months and has been the most labor
intensive and larger scale Endeavor
we've ever worked on collectively but it
has been so worth it getting the
opportunity to share with you all why
this Series has been so important to us
as being gratifying to say the least but
we can't celebrate just yet because
we've still gotta save the world from
Majin Buu and analyze what concluded the
final Mainline original Arc pinned and
illustrated by Akira Toriyama be honest
when we first began painting this final
ax analysis the plan was to do it as
simply one video despite the anime's
version of events taking up a huge chunk
of the series The manga's volume length
isn't at all that different from the
previous arcs and yet with such a
shake-up to the formula and almost reset
of the story it became clear that doing
Justice to this compelling character Arc
found in the first part of the story
wouldn't have been possible in one video
and that character were culminated in
this stunning conclusion to Vegeta's
character Arc itself and it's here the
plot almost begins again Anew and I mean
that in a good way in the same fashion
that the Saiyan Saga transitioned
naturally into the Frieza material so
too does Vegeta sacrifice flow into this
with a natural cause and effect and all
because this story we're about to Embark
upon had seeds planted forward in the
first half you see following the
aftermath of Vegeta's final atonement we
are very much in the new phase of this
overall Arc where the previous material
focused largely on the dichotomy between
Generations old and new what follows is
the natural conclusion to that a focus
on the final passing of the torch and
the sequence of consequences that come
of the prior Generations actions at this
point it almost feels as though Toriyama
felt satisfied with his conclusion of
Vegeta's story and by extension Goku's
in the cell Arc so going forward into
this material we begin to feel a
distinct change would in which all
characters involved in this younger
generation are given their time to find
their place in the world discover
themselves and see where it all takes
them and when I say all characters I do
mean all an interesting Wrinkle In This
arcs formula is that the villain himself
Majin Buu is also cast in that same lot
while trunks Goten and even Gohan are
obviously given time in the coming
material to find their footing and place
in the story so too does Boo participate
in this series of self-discoveries and
so with Majin Buu left in ruin following
Vegeta's final explosion we pick up the
story exactly where we left off with
Goten and Trunks the only remaining
Saiyans left to fight
so you're new I'm God you can call me
Dandy skd if you're feeling spicy
welcome to Mikasa oh um I'm Fidel
daughter of Mr Satan the devil in God's
house gotta love it oh yeah I'm actually
a friend of Gohan oh oh you're you're
goings friend a friend who just happens
to be a girl a girlfriend if you would
with your nice long human legs and uh
normal colored skin well I mean I
wouldn't say normal that's got a lot of
uncomfortable implications you know
speaking of have you met Mr Popo hi oh
my God are you allowed
Goten and Trunks reduce the stone the
facade of the once living Saiyan Prince
crashes to the ground below shattered
into a million pieces all the while the
shredded fragments of Majin Buu start to
rejoin and regenerate many could look
pessimistically at this sacrifice as one
that was made in vain and I suppose in
many ways it is and it's a fitting one
who's routinely selfish actions had dire
consequences however I never saw it as
simply Toriyama giving Vegeta his
comeuppance the fact that Vegeta was
willing to do something like that for
the people he loves is reward in and of
itself on a character level even if it
ultimately achieves no material benefit
in the real world he is punished in body
but healed in mind and in seeing this
Piccolo formulates A desperate plan of
action understanding the current
circumstances to be that of Goku missing
in action at best all the while Vegeta
and Gohan are in his mind confirmed to
be dead the fate of the world and the
entire universe now rest squarely on the
small but promising shoulders of two
boys under the age of 10 who have
shattered expectations time and time
again and meanwhile babidi and Majin Buu
fly off together to cause yet more
trouble on planet Earth
[Music]
I'm concerning the current Goten and
trunk story this narrative wrinkle this
choice to place Goku not at the
Forefront of the story in a traditional
sense is enthralling to say the least
Goku the last Bastion of considerable
strength to stand against Majin Buu is
in the process of once again Vanishing
from this realm in a matter of hours
it's enormously compelling stuff with
significant tension and in my view
nothing better captures the themes of
passing the torch in this Arc then this
training sequence right here shifting
back into the mentor role Goku claims
that he's just as strong as Vegeta and
cannot beat boo but that the boys can
with a technique he learned a technique
he doesn't have a partner to perform it
with but the boys do the Fusion Dance a
coordinated movement between two equal
sized individuals with similar strength
that when performed correctly can enable
the movers to unite into one being for
30 minutes magnifying their strength
considerable at this stage in the story
the idea of taking two established
characters and effectively bashing them
together making a brand new one might
seem overly tried or perhaps a step too
far conceptually however much like any
ambitious decision made in this series I
think what matters the most when
designing a technique isn't so much its
ability to avoid jumping a shark so to
speak but instead how well it
complements the themes and narrative
it's housed with it and metaphorically I
think this is a brilliant technique for
this Arc specifically where the Saiyan
Saga played host to the debut of the
Genki dama a technique that acted as the
living embodiment of teamwork and
camaraderie the very themes of that
story so too does the Fusion Dance offer
a similar resonance to this one a
technique passed down to the Next
Generation a generation born from the
very characters whose selfish actions
doomed them in the first place together
they now have to combine and coordinate
their forces like the prior generation
couldn't to create a counter-offensive
far greater than the sum of its parts
far are greater than their parents it's
a phenomenally appropriate and poignant
thematic move and a fantastic addition
to this series and additionally a brief
Ray of Hope that shines Upon Our Heroes
as the Diabolical bobbity makes a
violent threat to the entire world if
Trunks and Goten don't come out of
hiding and face them they will blow up
the Earth in five days and with that
threat issued a time limit has been
placed Goku will be long returned to
other world in that time frame and no
one else is alive on Earth that can make
a difference it'll just be the boys
under Piccolo's tutelage
this is an emotionally powerful scene
two children at the end of the day have
a frankly unfair amount of pressure
placed on their shoulders to achieve
what neither of their Idols were able to
achieve defeat the seemingly
undefeatable Majin Buu and save the
world and this feels all the more
incredible of an ask when we recall just
how awe-inspired these kids have been
when looking at what Gohan was capable
of and what Vegeta was capable of where
Goku Vegeta and even Gohan who at the
time could rely on Piccolo massively
were afford slow build ups to what was
ultimately expected of them Trunks and
Goten literally need to go from zero to
hero in a matter of days however while
they are the ones tasked with making the
counter-offensive against Buu they
aren't entirely alone either armed with
the guidance of the single most
accomplished and impressive fighter to
ever come in to existence possibly Son
Goku and while his time spent training
the boys is fleeting it is perhaps one
of my favorite incarnations of Goku's
character in this series he's
appropriately serious but with a
measured air of kindness and Duty behind
him but the most fascinating part of it
all is while the likes of Piccolo Gohan
and Vegeta understand who Goku is what
he's done what he knows what he stands
for and what he's capable of neither
trunks or even his own Son Goten
understands or respects him by default
they even snap at him laying the blame
on him for allowing their Heroes to die
verbally lashing out claiming that he's
supposed to be some sort of big shot and
he let them all down and what makes this
scene all the more powerful is while
these are indeed childish outbursts that
signal the fear and despair they must be
feeling at this time for the most part
go to the trunks aren't wrong Goku did
did let them down more than they even
know it's such a raw scene and when a
scene has a heightened tension or raw
emotion on display like this it offers
up the chance for characters to
demonstrate who they are in a powerful
way for when pressure is applied to a
character that's when we find out who
they are in a story and how does Goku
demonstrate who he truly is by not
correcting them by not accepting
Piccolo's help when talking to them Goku
doesn't care for nor does he want their
respect and he's their only option
because he's the only one who didn't
make the same mistakes their Idols Gohan
and Vegeta made in many respects but he
would never say that he has no ego about
this he just wants to get the boys ready
as best he can because he cares about
them and the world that's on the line
and as best he can in the same way he
tried to guide Vegeta's mindset Goku
tries to channel this negative energy
the boys exhibit into positive
measurable action and following another
interjection from the deranged babidi
and the Monstrous Majin Buu Goku has but
one thing to ask them
this scene from start to finish is some
of the strongest character writing in
the arc and an outstanding example of
toriyama's continued unwavering
understanding of the Goku character one
that begins with the boys unimpressed
but when all is said and done they will
know the true scope of character that
stands before them they won't need
Piccolo or even Goku to tell them who he
is they will see it for themselves
through Goku's own actions
foreign
was like support the official release
and you guys are always like well we
would but he's not available in our
country well first of all
that's exceptionally rude well we have a
solution for you my friends nordvpn of
kindly sponsored today's video and are
offering you guys four months for free
for their two-year plan just head over
to nordvpn.com forward slash toy not
markvpn or click the link in the
description and you guys can jump in
with a totally pain-free install nothing
is more infuriating than hopping onto
Crunchyroll or Netflix and saying sorry
Lads no videos available here but with
nordvpn you can just click on one of the
US servers hit refresh and
boom free anime for all happy days right
but if you're a gamer who likes to watch
I don't know anime on the side and
you're like ew my ping is so high with
the VPN well nor have you covered too
simply enable their split tunneling
option add your browser or streaming app
and just like that it'll be the only
thing affected by the VPN no more hyping
in game it is literally a game changer
hahaha very funny so if that sounds good
to you once again please click the link
in the description and or head to
nordvpn.com forward slash toy not
markvpn and you can hop on their
two-year plan with four months for free
and hey if you don't like it you can get
a 30 day money back guarantee
[Music]
foreign
with their first demonstration of their
abilities from the beginning of this Arc
Vegeta Gohan as well as many other
individuals have been amazed Time and
Again by the scope and ability of these
two young Saiyans much the same way Goku
grew up impressing countless characters
with his prowess so too have these two
young children demonstrated a similar
pattern of behavior and upon request to
power up to maximum we're given every
reason to believe the same will be true
for this scene but Goku isn't anybody
simply says quote is that it there and
then acting as the subversion to this
established trend of behavior and
additionally a further reminder of just
how much farther these two boys need to
go in order to even get onto Goku's
level now that's what I call being
concise and efficient with your dialogue
which is important as right after this
interaction Bobby chimes in once more
this time informing them that capsule
Corp will be their next Target in the
hopes of flushing out Trunks and perhaps
others hiding there at this stage we're
already after begrudgingly accepting
that the Dragon Balls will be relied
upon to bring their loved ones back to
life like their grandparents and
presently Bulma and the Gang are already
at the lookout but what they can't get
back is the dragon radar and suddenly
what was an uncomfortable situation to
have to contend with has become a tense
and time-sensitive emergency one that
places a tremendous amount of emphasis
on trunks to covertly infiltrate his own
home on scene now tasked with improving
the radar all the while Goku uses
everything he has left to stall against
Majin Buu
you're going to love this
trust me
Super Saiyan 3. as a scene that takes
place within the context of this
training sequence thematically it's a
strong and necessary inclusion in many
respects the story that's being told
between these three characters is that
of two talented but unfocused and
inexperienced children learning from an
older more experienced master and due to
their lack of experience both in general
and with the hero in question initially
they can't fully appreciate the master
that stands before them despite the
legend and Prestige behind the name Goku
that even we are aware of Trunks and
Goten have felt let down and resentful
of them for not fixing these
circumstances himself to the point that
they question his ability and over
inflate their own I liked this approach
because it places the audience in a
rather strange position in Star Wars
when it came time for Luke to train with
Yoda he does so as our own point of view
character in other words once we meet
Yoda we know about as much info
information concerning him as Luke does
and when Yoda busts out what makes him
special later like Luke we are impressed
and shocked however with this initial
training before Goku reveals Super
Saiyan 3 the dynamic is very much the
opposite for us as viewers we know less
about goated and Trunks and far more
about Goku's exploits we can understand
how angry they are but we can also
appreciate the depth of their ignorance
and that Dynamic continues until we
reach the scene in question a scene
Toriyama sees fit to Primus for
specifically for instance the moment
Goku suggests he's going to stall the
monster trunks asks are you sure I mean
can you won't they just flatten you
instantly to which Goku calmly responds
I'll manage leaving trunks to run off
uncertain
yo quite brilliantly three things are
achieved in the scene that follows
number one talking with Bobby and boo
initially Goku flexes his subtle
understanding of social dynamics
planting the seeds in Boo's mind that
will ultimately flourish into Bobby's
downfall number two as Goku begins to
cycle through his various forms Goten
and Trunks are forced to fully
appreciate and comprehend the scope of
their own misunderstandings as Goku
turns Super Saiyan trunks even remarks
that he's as strong as his own Idol his
father and then of course he goes one
step further Beyond even that once he
does they understand that Goku is as
much of a legend as they've heard of and
then some he's exceeded their
expectations and finally number three
and this is my favorite and I think the
most sophisticated part of this
narrative development this is an aspect
of Goku's character that we at home too
are totally unaware of by revealing this
technique Super Saiyan 3 to this is an
audience we switch from being onlookers
who understand more about Goku than the
two boys and for a brief moment in time
are just as shocked and surprised as
they are this is a wonderful shared
experience made to connect us with these
two young characters
is to go even further Beyond
[Applause]
[Music]
I think many might come away from this
transformation with the impression that
it's a bit of a letdown and if we look
at it through the lens of this scene
needing to live up to the same Fanfare
and impact the prior two Transformations
offered I think it's undeniable and
understandable that folks feel somewhat
let down by this moment however it's my
view that Super Saiyan 3 at least at
this point in the story wasn't meant to
be some magnificent reveal to rival
either of the prior forms on an
emotional narrative or even mechanical
level but instead was revealed to
establish a connection between the two
boys and us at home as they prepare to
take this metaphorical Torch from who
they can now see was in fact all along
the strongest under the heavens a man
who was strong enough not to brag show
off or show insecurity a man who wants
the very best for them and expects the
best from them and I think when observed
through the context of what's just
happened this is a great scene however
regrettably much like many other scenes
in this Arc the contents of this moment
will be hurt retroactively by creative
choices that take place later but in the
interest of structure I'll save those
talking points for when those moments
themselves arrive
first off we got good old Super Saiyan
everyone knows this one wait you
seriously just put super at the
beginning of it that's kind of lazy if
you ask man this oh okay it's a super
duper Sans you don't look I mean is
there a difference I I literally cannot
tell these are those happy sacks see oh
this is to go even further Beyond
[Music]
oh no go ahead don't waste the last of
the time you have their whipping out
your dead
oh you hear that I feel that I taste
that
what's that smell
[Applause]
[Music]
s
like this is a super deep Super Saiyan
I'm just going to call those Super
Saiyan one two and three okay that's
boring
oh very bored we fight now sure
thank you
it's been said both by toriyama's
critics and Toriyama himself that he
struggles to write relationships love
and romance and while I absolutely agree
with this assessment of him I did notice
something on this read through that
didn't catch my eye on prior reviews of
the material it's small so don't expect
the world here but I did think it was
kinda Sweet Moments after Goku returns
to the lookout after burning through the
remainder of his time left on Earth we
see him saying his goodbyes to his wife
Chichi reassuring her that once he gets
to Otherworld he'll make sure to say hi
to Gohan for her but this sweet moment
is interrupted by Videl taking Goku to
one side she says that she can't explain
it but she feels that Gohan is alive and
when I saw this moment it reminded me of
something similar I saw during the
Fallout of Vegeta's sacrifice following
the tearful farewell to the Saiyan
Prince the first voice we hear is in
krillin's piccolos or anyone else that's
more prevalent in the story instead we
immediately hear from Bulma whose
reflect on the horror she's seen unfold
before her a character that we've not
really heard much from at all this Arc
suddenly the atmosphere shakes and an
unease Falls over Bulma specifically
concerning her husband almost as if she
into it something grave happened to
Vegeta that very moment that's about as
far as it goes but to me it's
interesting that Videl and Bulma are
both intrinsically tied to their
respective Partners in ways other far
more prominent characters like Goku
aren't
[Music]
Sumo Genie in a cape is a deceptively
complicated character masquerading as a
simple one I at least during this
material there are some interesting
scenes too that reveal this at point in
the story he's killed about two-thirds
of the Earth's total population a stats
so massive it's become hard to even
Envision accurately in our minds from
the moment he's being released booze
acted like a terrifying child bent on
destruction and satisfying his own
fleeting desires however the first
indication we get that there's more to
him than meets the eye comes to our
attention when he stumbles across a
little blind boy on his travels and this
is noteworthy because unlike every
single other person booze ever
encountered this little kid isn't afraid
of him he doesn't show him hatred or
fear naturally this takes Boo by
surprise and in the interest of
restoring normality back to his own life
boo cures the child's blindness
anticipating that he will then show him
the same reaction all the others have
once he sees him but he doesn't instead
the young child struggling for money
gives boo everything he has as thanks
for this miracle he's performed boo
naturally tries to eat it and later says
that it tastes bad before turning more
people he finds into milk to give to the
child and while that is horrifying in
its own right with him continuing his
aimless destruction of the planet
moments later it should start to become
obvious that there's more taboo than a
simple monster hell bent on satisfying
his own evil desires
[Music]
this sequence which acts as the
conclusion to what has been Goten and
trunks's training for the most part is
the area of the story in which I think
lost a lot of steam in the anime for me
in truth this first unveiling of gotenk
serves three functions to introduce us
to Gotenks obviously to inform us of the
risks and subtlety involved in
performing the Fusion dance and of
course a massive amount of Snappy gag
comedy we've all seen the Fusion Dance
fail resulting in the fat and skinny
incarnations of the characters designs
results and gags that were largely
recycled during the Gogeta segment of
the Broly movie in 2018 that is all
funny look at the fat kid run but truly
this sequence of the story has
everything from toriyama's gag manga
utility belt everything from slapstick
to fourth wall breaks to naming
conventions however when it comes to the
anime I almost felt like this was the
moment where the story started to lose
me and it's because this wasn't supposed
to be the first time we see Gotenks
fight boo in the manga this is where we
see goat tanks for the very first time
the first successful result of the
Fusion dance but ultimately still it is
just a stepping stone towards the
finishing line that Piccolo has in mind
for the dance to truly work they
according to Piccolo need to be super
saiyan while performing the dance
however gotenks's trademark ego gets the
better of him and he flies off to fight
Buu only for him too moments later
return battered and bruised it's a
cutaway gag having received his
comeuppance this is a visual gag or
punch line there isn't even any
indication as to how he escaped Boo's
clutches when he did but that's okay
because this is a random throwaway gag
the anime however decides to turn this
into an entire fight to treat it far
more seriously one that sees goten's
Escape running the risk of taking away
Boo's Prestige all for a fight that
isn't anywhere near as good as what
their first fight ultimately is in the
manga
[Music]
foreign
whoa look it finally worked they fused
into it actually what do we call you you
can call me the miraculous truck
go
okay which one am I going with well I
mean trumpton sounds weird but Gotenks
is like all Goten and a little trucks
and I both know how this Stacks but yeah
it does sound better okay they're not
going with goat tanks but I owe me later
yeah I know hold on then do we use he
him or they them wise not non-binary
well definitely not there's two of them
in there no yeah that's kind of my point
you kids and your pronouns
wait
all I'm saying is back in my day a hole
was a hole
gross
there are more subversions like this
leading up to their first fight with a
second timer Rising by way of their
successful achievement of the Super
Saiyan Fusion Dance following the
successful fusion and some training they
rushed to Boo's house only for them to
infuse the moment they arrive at the
house again the second attempt is kept
life it's a gag but lucky for us third
time's the charm but before that we have
Mr Satan and Majin Buu
foreign
of the three groupings I wanted to talk
about during this training interlude
Majin Buu and Mr Satan's contribution
while brief was perhaps the most funny
and rewarding with the military having
failed in the world after losing hope
the future of the planet is placed on
the shoulders of the very champion who
bested cell the current reigning
strongest under the heavens Martial Arts
Tournament winner Mr Satan at face value
this sequence of development seems so
insanely wild that it's hard not to be
enthralled I mean I spent over three
hours total talking on the cell Saga as
well as the first half of the Buu saga
and I somehow managed to almost avoid
talking about Mr Satan entirely but
that's not because I don't like the
character quite the opposite in fact
it's just that the way Satan is
introduced to us is intentionally one
note one dimensional and four laughs he
is not really meant at almost any point
to be taken seriously as a character
outside of his one interaction with
Android 16 but therein lies The Genius
of these upcoming developments through
the previous dozens of volumes of manga
we have explored pretty much every
character in the roster extensively even
minor characters like tenshinon have had
their character depths plunged all the
way through to the cell Saga so when it
came time to find a partner for boo in
this tale there were of course a great
many suited characters to choose from
but instead of that instead of reaching
back into the established well Toriyama
chose to explore and in the process holy
reinvent this one note character those
depths to his character which will be
revealed they're enthralling because of
just how unexpected they are and much
the same can be said from Majin Buu as
well and fittingly in this entirely
offbeat Saga where gags have taken
precedence over action and the intense
atmosphere we've come to expect from
Dragon Ball Z's previous arcs in many
respects the chapter chronicling the
attempted infiltration and execution of
Boo at the hands of Mr Satan is more
exciting with each passing page on one
hand we have a character in Mr Satan who
is a walking embodiment of dramatic
irony as an audience we know he has
absolutely no chance and what's more is
we know he knows that too on some level
and on the other hand and we have Majin
Buu a character that is at this juncture
about as unpredictable as the weather in
Ireland and this combination of Satan
and boo right off the bat creates a very
unfamiliar atmosphere it's exciting but
in a strange way it almost feels like a
different manga in some respects with
toriyama's more creative paneling almost
intentionally being simplified to parse
out a very gag focused story its
Simplicity almost resembles a comic
strip boasting exaggerated facial
expressions and action that wouldn't
feel out of place in an episode of
Looney Tunes some of these Expressions
even remind me of some of Chuck Jones's
best work but this visual Simplicity
covers a much more interesting and
subtle story when Mr Satan came
splashing onto the scene during cell and
continued on throughout this Saga he's
initially depicted as a blowhard comic
relief character and in that role he
found a lot of success however as time
rolled on and as he took credit for
things he quite literally could not do
transforming his own life in the process
on the back of other people's work while
the heroes of this story didn't care we
as an audience at home sort of did and
alongside the returning Son Goku he
almost represented the very worst of
modern martial arts in this world one
that neither Goku nor Piccolo saw much
value in comparing to what they grew up
with
this man lived a lie and as a result the
world loved him for it he went from the
world's martial arts Champion to the
world savior a title and level of Fame
he covets more than his own material
wealth and because of that desire to
perpetuate this lie he's found himself
in increasingly dire circumstances
circumstances that have now led him to
the door of the fabled monster Majin Buu
a being responsible for now killing over
80 percent of the Earth's population but
all of that context expectation and
preamble to this encounter is exactly
what makes this scene itself so
effective despite his greatest efforts
to be something he's not Mr Satan
doesn't stop Majin Buu because he's the
toughest or strongest he stops him by
simply taking an approach that is
entirely true to him and who he is the
champion liar of the world ended up
saving it by being genuine and I love
that on the other side of the coin Buu
came into this world knowing only manipu
and fear he sought out the latter and
through doing so comes across a small
injured puppy he takes it back to Satan
specifically because he didn't treat him
or react to him like the others have
like how he expects everything to react
to him however once he heals it for the
explicit purpose of making it run away
and then killing it
pop loves boo through Mr Satan and
indeed bathe the poppy Boos introduced
to and becomes fond of the feeling of
being loved and appreciated and he does
so because this is the very first time
he's ever felt anything like this I mean
Mr Satan asks him why do you kill and
destroy and boo responds they said that
it's how you play Bibbidi and Bobbidi
and with that brief innocent explanation
suddenly we see the root of Boo's nature
isn't evil it's simply misguided
innocence simply manipulated by cruel
tyrannical small creatures and just like
that because Buu likes Mr Satan and
because Mr Satan simply floats the idea
by him Majin Buu there and then quits
killing
he
Ma
the scene where Bay is shot is emotional
for me you can see how devastated boo is
how close he is to snapping and how he's
holding himself in place not killing
because he was asked not to he's so
desperately trying to keep the promise
he made to his now best friend it seems
so unfair that mere moments after making
up his mind on that the very worst of
humanity shows up and tries to take
something so important from him the
creature that showed him love for the
very first time but this is where Mr
Satan steps in and shows that while
alongside the demigods of this series he
might look unimpressive in the grand
scheme of things he's more than capable
and through Mr Satan's first actions in
this story he's able to take out these
Thugs and alert boo to Bay's fading life
force in time for him to save him but
this is where the most interesting part
of Boo's character comes into play or
rather is tested Mr Satan is shot in the
back and boo is again enraged more
Furious than we've ever seen him he
bends over to heal Mr Satan with a
special emphasis on his hands shaking in
the manga hardly able to contain the
swell of negative emotion that no doubt
resides within him he wants to not kill
but these monsters have pushed him to
the Edge of Reason and honestly in a
similar fashion to how Kami described
Piccolo was formed and ultimately purged
from himself due to the evils of
humanity boo 2 purges himself of all the
negative and evil in his system brought
about by the evils of humanity creating
a skinny gray husk of a boo one that
doesn't hold this new value or promise
not to kill it's a brilliant sequence
and culmination to what has been some of
the best chapters in this Arc the first
thing this new wrathful boo does it's
not confronting his former self it's
slaughtering the man who dared tried to
take what he values the most Mr Satan
clearly the impetus for this Outburst
clearly what pink boo was holding
himself back from doing and from there
we get quite literally a clash of ideals
as this new evil boo begins to fight
with the established fat Boo and
unfortunately it very quickly becomes
apparent that the Kinder boo is
outclassed a clear metaphor that the
pent-up trauma that Boo has harbored
being more potent than his Newfound
kindness the manga's narration makes
this point all the clearer quote alas
sweetness stands little chance against
concentrated wrath and with that it is
only a measly page later where Boo's own
chocolate beam is turned against him and
the evaboo establishes himself as the
dominant entity chapters upon chapters
of buildup can careful character work
between Satan and boo all gone to waste
at the hands of Pure Evil both in terms
of the gunman that triggered all of this
as well as the deep-seated evil that lay
dormant withinbu from his centuries of
Destruction at the whims of bibidi and
Bobbidi
[Music]
laughs
Super Boom is boring and naturally the
dynamic of the story shifts instantly
what was previously a moment of
scrambling intermission with both sides
of the war going through self-discovery
has now zeroed into a singular
undeniable threat the power of Majin Buu
and then some with the unfiltered wrath
that lie within him now in the driver's
seat
well hungry doggy did you know boo Will
You Naughty Dogs we're all confused if
humans eat cows and pigs why do we eat
dogs because they're cute domesticated
and functional so say Breeze and boo not
eat you yes
oh come on they're overpriced
that's worse
just don't eat people no more use your
magic and turn rocks into food
people no more
no more eat rocks instead wait a second
Humanity
I saved the world
everything's gonna be
[Music]
super Buu's introduction into the story
imposes a sense of intense severity with
a considerably higher degree of
seriousness and this is reflected in his
design I spoke on Majin Buu's design
when he was initially revealed and waxed
the lyrical about how much I loved it
and I think given what Super Buu is
bringing this story in terms of a more
serious and dire atmosphere his design
reflects that by being importantly
different to the original fat boo shapes
are interesting lenses through which to
analyze how different designs manipulate
our feelings towards particular
character triangles can be particularly
fun as they can be either supremely
stable or entirely off balance the genie
from Aladdin is a great example of an
upside down triangle with rounded
circular features the reason I love this
design is that because magic is integral
to his character to reflect that aspect
in his character's shape he was
intentionally drawn to be balanced on
what is effectively the tip of one of
the triangles points and never loses
balance this creates a sense of unease
but also a sense of magic within the
character Majin Buu is this Design's
approach but flipped on its head he's a
right side up triangle so to speak with
circular rounded shapes typically this
sort of triangle is reserved for
villains but there's an aspect to his
design that's quite disarming his gentle
rounded shapes almost as if to create a
contrast with his actions or to betray
an underlying innocence Underneath It
All however as we saw when he split into
a second boo was created with a very
different look and even when he later
absorbs the old fatter boo to become
super Boo this new form reflects far
less uplifting energy no longer a
triangle no longer circular instead he
is one of the most square and
rectangular designs in the entire series
which is appropriate given what he
offers now to the story in terms of a
tonal shift stripping boo of everything
that made him likable leaving behind
nothing but Less Fun more matter-of-fact
shape however as we will soon see with
The Walking personification of
toriyama's urge to write a gag manga boo
2 retains many of the characteristics
his all-rounder counterpart had in terms
of a comedic timing albeit with a much
more Sinister Heir and while Gohan
continues his adventures in the plane of
the kaioshin elsewhere and don't worry I
have an entire section written for Gohan
specifically later this new super boot
takes immediate action in driving the
plot forward at full speed
foreign
[Music]
this is the most effective tense seen in
maybe the whole Arc for me there's a
compelling reason for all parties to act
as they do and furthermore there's a
clever use of time to gain specific
advantages and my god do I love this
it's equal parts horrifying as it is
intelligent and at times funny the tone
significantly changes after this section
too so let's enjoy it while we can the
circumstances are quite simple Buu has
gained the ability to sense Ki and
through doing so has located Trunks and
Goten on the lookout currently they are
sleeping and the only one capable of
buying them time is Piccolo within the
first half of this Arc Piccolo
specifically had virtually nothing to do
emphasized by the fact that he spent
most of the runtime of this Arc as a
statue however this scene offers him the
opportunity to leverage his ability to
think and remain level-headed in a
circumstance that would almost certainly
result in utter failure for every other
character in this story where Goku and
Vegeta might resort to a more physical
approach way too soon knowing that he's
outmatched Piccolo uses his mind and the
most compelling part is we know about as
much information as Piccolo does at this
time so we along with him have to
formulate a plan in real time face to
face with this pink monstrosity however
in trying to stall Majin Buu further
knowing that they are already at their
last resort and need to rely on the
Dragon Balls to return all of those
killed back to life Piccolo tells boo
that the boys will in fact fight him but
only after he's finished killing the
remaining humans on planet Earth
and what unfolds is perhaps one of the
most chilling scenes in the entire
series
challenge
walking right up to Piccolo looking at
him with Unbreaking eye contact and
minimal effort standing atop the
structure that's supposed to offer
guardianship over the people of this
planet Majin Buu effortlessly erases
every single last person on Earth from
existence save for one or two telling
exceptions the entire sequence really
drives home how much the dynamic has
shifted what was once a foe that gave
them a lot of wiggle room is now an
absolutely Relentless Force searching
for a backup plan he sees Videl and says
that she Mr Satan's daughter wants you
to wait one hour and brilliantly boo
accepts meanwhile Piccolo informs
Krillin to take the boys into the room
of spirit and time for training one hour
might not be a lot of time in the real
world but within the room that one hour
turns to 15 solid days of training what
an amazing strategy however while these
characters have largely been relegated
to gag Centric actions during this story
in this scene the emotional icing on the
cake is yet to reveal itself moments
before the boys are taken into the room
Goten and Trunks see boo kill Chichi
before their very ice enraged and now
refocused with a raw sense of purpose
the two young Saiyans prepare for the
most physically and emotionally
challenging fight of their young lives
unfortunately however the patience Boo
has exhibited to make this possible in
the first place is about to run out
before they expected it to things just
got a lot more tense and this is why I
love this scene so much Piccolo is
managing all of this brilliantly buying
the kids as much time as he can walking
the Long Way to the room and through
using his psychic connection Piccolo
tells them to rest up eat and sleep
because he's buying them an extra minute
and I just adore how Toriyama presents
this in the manga we see all of this
from Piccolo's side of the conversation
once he hangs up the proverbial phone
once Piccolo stops communication between
himself Goten and Trunks he exchanges
one or two lines with boo they arrive
quite quickly at the door and boo walks
in no longer unprepared there he is
greeted by two young and determined
Saiyans completely rested waiting for
him to open that very door it's a
wonderful moment leveraging the boy's
Flair for the dramatic Piccolo's
intelligence and the room's mechanics
it's just a wonderful moment
foreign
opinions I might have had concerning
Gotenks in the anime at this point can
be ignored largely as the moment is far
more significant in the manga and I say
this because I recall watching this very
scene in the anime and being rather
bored by it due to the fact that I'd
already seen so much of Gotenks by this
point and had even seen him fight with
Majin Buu specifically there was no real
attraction left for me to experience
anymore just another random fight I had
already seen time and again however in
the manga this is the very first time
we've ever seen Gotenks in action and
what's more is it's under extremely
bizarre circumstances in a location
we've never seen people fighting in
before with contrasting character
Dynamics being the order of the day
Piccolo is desperate and serious all the
while gold tanks is sufficiently
childish holding back his power in the
hopes of wowing his audience of one the
pace of this fight additionally is very
different to pretty much any fight in
the modern material the tone of the
affair feels very much like a couple of
super powered children fighting playing
with each other one being told one woman
not to move all the while the other
tries out special secret techniques and
this Choice gives the fight this
entirely distinct feeling for better or
worse than any other fight in recent
memory
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hey wait Uncle Napa hey kids how's it
hanging what are you doing here oh yeah
so I was having a stroke in my trailer
and it did not end well our condolences
it's my fault shouldn't have made that
extra notch in the belt I don't get it
ask trunks dad but he's dead
am I doing here oh no oh
yeah the super ghost Kamikaze attack is
my personal favorite of gotenks's
Arsenal and one of the funniest moves in
all the series this does for comedy what
the Kaioken does for action it's such a
fun idea and perfect for this tone of
fight in a saga like this boo is
Additionally the perfect villain to
entertain this sort of foolishness and
furthermore the combination of Piccolo's
straight man mixed with gotenks's
overzealous idiot is a match made in
heaven both comedically and narratively
the entire fight is pretty much
chock-full with Toriyama having the time
of his life with fun gags not even
Justin gotenks's silly moves but moments
like cutting taboo having already
regenerated long ago now sipping on a
milkshake it is the ultimate mix of
Dragon Ball Z's giant Power Scope and
toriyama's love for the silly much like
some of the fights in the early
Tenkaichi budokai's the jump from whoa
that's cool to laughing are constant
unfortunately ever obsessed with
creating a dramatic fight goten's hide
Super Saiyan 3 and pretends to be out of
energy which naturally forces Piccolo to
take a drastic measure destroying the
door to the room trapping them all
inside I love this sequence of the story
it's Snappy doesn't overstay its welcome
and it's around this point where the
musaga starts to show its cracks despite
having sung the Praises of this section
in a fashion I never thought I would for
as long as I have as soon as Piccolo
locks them all inside this room a choice
I loved by the way when I read it
because this strategy by Piccolo was
smart and foolproof it turns out it was
too smart and too foolproof because
within seconds Buu escapes through
screaming sure why not I don't like this
because it kind of feels cheap but what
really irks me is that these are the
conditions we see Gotenks reveal Super
Saiyan 3 under not to Brave himself
against some Almighty foe but instead to
scream seem like an idiot to get out of
a room now these are all nitpicks and if
this was all there was to the scene I'd
be able to get past it relatively
quickly however there is more earlier I
acknowledged the power and emotion
generated by Goten seeing his mother
killed by boo before his very eyes
changing both of the children's
respective demeanors in an instant
taking one of the lessons he learned
from his father before he left and
putting it into practice that being
channeling that very rage into
motivation and results however when we
next check in on the two boys they are
having fun feeling confident in the room
I thought this made sense personally and
the fight that took place in the room
thereafter felt similarly light-hearted
I really liked that decision because at
the end of the day go to the trunks
these are kids and kids are easily
distracted at that point they had been
alone goofing around in a room for a
solid week together so it's all gravy
with me here but when they do get out
and was revealed to have eaten all of
their friends and family in the seconds
it took them to get out the fact that
the tone of the fight didn't change even
remotely it just really sucked me out of
the fight and more than that just made
me not care at all it killed the pacing
we've already seen gotenks's gag fueled
fighting and now should have been the
time where the kids got angry but
instead we just continue with the silly
gag fighting we see him telling Piccolo
to serve up the volleyball for him to
spike it it's a funny joke but dudes he
killed your parents your orphans now the
anime adds a meaningful and appropriate
reaction to this news the manga
otherwise didn't and I honestly really
appreciated that look at this reaction
it nailed the tone I was thinking about
but the fight that ensued afterwards
still remained as light-hearted as ever
fighting that even if we ignore how it
undercuts the stakes is still a style of
fight best suited to Short
and right now it's going on just that
little bit too long it's a gag that I'm
not finding humor in anymore and outside
of that despite all of the prep the two
powerful children with a great story
couldn't get the job done and as some of
the last remaining inhabitants on planet
Earth
seems Boo's Victory is all but assured
[Applause]
the return of Gohan from the early
moments of that first video I wrote in
this Dragon Ball Z review series I
defined it as the story of Goku and also
the rise of Son Gohan a tale that
chronicled his climb from powerless
young child to powerful young man one
that saw him confronted with the horrors
of humanity and beyond all the way to
his defining moment in the series one
that any and every fan of the story
rightfully touts as a pivotal moment for
him however it might have also occurred
to some of you that during this video in
particular I've made mention of Gohan
maybe once why is that well I'm a big
fan of what Gohan can offer this story
and what's more is in one way or another
while reading this material even when
Gohan failed to stop the release of
Majin Buu this story to me still felt as
though it was in the process of telling
an exceptionally strong story for his
character one that I was very excited to
see however what follows while strong in
places ultimately ends in a less than
ideal situation for him and US creating
a feeling that perhaps our time
following the character Faithfully
through this Arc was in some measure
wasted during this review I
intentionally refrain from speaking
about Gohan and I did so to help
illustrate that outside of his own
little self-contained story with the
Kai's Gohan's exploits during his
training material had little to no
impact on anyone other than himself
until this very moment while Boo and the
two boys impacted each other's stories
rather directly Gohan's contributions to
the story begin From This Moment he
touches down on Earth with everything
that came before largely concerning
itself with comedic moments of levity to
cut away to I should mention that this
isn't necessarily a bad thing either it
just puts a lot of pressure on what
happens when Gohan does eventually show
up to make the save on Earth Goku's
character offered a very similar dynamic
as he was traveling to Namek he didn't
impact the group at all and until he
arrived and so just like Goku arrives on
Namek Gohan's journey and contribution
made during his training portion will
largely be defined by how his character
is used following this moment of heroism
against Majin Buu and so before I really
dive into the Weeds on this one it's
probably a good idea to run through what
his story and training are convolved
what worked for me what didn't and where
I thought there was a very clear
Direction implemented that could have if
approached correctly granted Gohan one
of the strongest moments in his entire
run in this story
the Z sword after losing some steam
during the Majin Vegeta material Gohan's
story really started to pick itself up
during this training section convincing
everyone including Goku that he's being
killed and set Gohan up for that
incredible save moment on his brother I
touched on earlier which is honestly
some nice use of dramatic irony
furthermore the circumstances he's
rescued from really speak to the
tendency of shin who at the time was
hanging on by a threat willing to walk
literal miles through desert and Forest
to find and save Gohan thankfully he
didn't need to due to the wish made and
the dragon balls and kabito was given
another important job healing Shin they
quickly locate Gohan and transport him
to the land of the kais where we really
get down to business much the same way
Goten and trunks's training goals were
laid before them by Goku Shin too
informs Gohan of his Destiny here to
remove the Fable Z sword from the stone
again I think this is a perfect story
for Gohan to undergo the legend of King
Arthur pulling the sword from the stone
is a pro typical chosen one type story
plucking an unassuming Arthur from
squalor granting him a chance to prove
himself and become the rightful King of
England naturally in the case of this
story Toriyama is repurposing this myth
if Gohan can pull the sword from the
stone supposedly he should be able to
slay Buu he would be the chosen one the
first in recorded knowledge according to
Shin to pull said sword from the stone
in addition to the obvious similarities
to the King Arthur Mythos this challenge
shares a lot in common with some of my
favorite training segments from Dragon
Ball's past there's a physical challenge
proposed the main character accepts and
through accepting he undergoes a process
to achieve this goal
foreign
well that was fast I am more than okay
with this creative decision too in fact
for going to show up and upon his first
serious try succeed in pulling the sword
from this Stone it follows the archetype
Toriyama is referencing to a T and
what's more is Toriyama finds a way to
make it funny when I think of The Sword
in the Stone I think of a little kid
pulling the sword not because he's
strong but instead because he's just
because he's the true king and this is
an enchanted sword however as Gohan
demonstrates what makes this sword tough
to pull wasn't his Chosen One Nest so to
speak just his ability to lift heavy
things and what's more is to further
subvert the myth Gohan hasn't been
bestowed with anything Supernatural all
he has now is a really heavy ass sword
which is hilarious following the Antics
with this sword returning from his scene
stealing moments with Goten and Trunks
Goku joins Gohan during his training
with the sword this I felt was a bit of
a missed opportunity and sort of felt
like Goku was added to this 6 for no
other reason Beyond Toriyama needing him
in a scene somewhere he offers plenty of
infectious energy to the scene but it
could have been cool to see him offer
advice or Direction when wielding the
sword to subvert the gag and actually
reveal some lesson sort of the same way
roshin quaranted for him back in the day
this isn't necessarily so much a
criticism as it is something I thought
could have rounded out his inclusion
here a bit more however with that said
he does instigate the instance that
progresses Gohan's story
foreign
I think your grandpa is here
[Music]
um excuse me sir who are you what are
your eyeballs for show peep the suit
kiddo I'm a kaiosheen Kyle what but how
and why were you in the sea sword before
I answered that can anyone here pop my
back
spent 75 million years sealed away in
that son of a oh because of that
bingis named B
wait a second who are they ah them
they're from the Mortal realm oh my what
are Morty's doing on our planet oh no
okay so this might be the hardest dance
I'll take on anything in this Arc anyone
out there that loves old Kai is
perfectly entitled to he has some good
gags and offers a lot of personality to
the mix however for me he represents
what I felt was robbed from Gohan in
this story to a certain extent not that
it was his fault he didn't write his own
role in the story roshi corn and other
Masters across this story have all been
disarming offbeat and in a word
eccentric memorable characters dwelling
within interesting circumstances with a
lot to offer our heroes if they can pass
their tests it's a simple but
foundational Dynamic established as
early as the first Arc of this series
and old Kai does indeed share some of
these qualities he's revealed in a
surprising fashion he's disarming to the
extreme seriously offbeat and dwells
within circumstances and a land unseen
by any mortal until Gohan and Goku
showed up but this is where the
comparisons end because unlike King Kai
unlike Horan unlike roshi there is is no
wax on wax off moment no lesson for
Gohan to intentionally or
unintentionally learn instead Gohan is
placed in a waiting room masquerading as
a wise Master training a young hero it's
precisely the sort of unearned power I
dislike and what's more is the very
presence of this scene which was
intersplaced between Goten and trunks's
moments served to rob their
contributions to the story of all their
tension because with this going on in
the background we knew all we were doing
was waiting for Gohan and with death
being treated as no consequence thanks
to the dragon balls now it just sucked
me further out of the story and really
emphasizes that Toriyama had nothing for
Gohan in this section of the story
outside of just waiting his turn and
looking at this overall Goten and Trunks
really got the better end of this
Arrangement tasked with cleaning up the
mistakes of their fathers they are on
the front lines and need to contend with
Incredible responsibility all the while
coming to grips with a threat they
couldn't possibly begin to understand
furthermore the training they undergo
makes sense a technique passed down by
the older generation that involves them
needing to learn cooperation and a
particular movement to perfect whereas
Gohan is quite literally I have nothing
for you now please sit down and wait
until it's your turn oh also here's a
free and totally unearned increase in
power that negates further consequence
that may arise due to your own lack of
training during the last seven years no
need to learn a lesson here I gotcha fam
and that's sort of what I dislike about
this there's no acknowledgment of
Gohan's failings no Lessons Learned no
real progression from this training
outside of a bigger number for his power
level to boast which wouldn't have been
an issue if this wasn't presented as the
grand moment Toriyama had been building
to in this training material
[Music]
oh what's wrong little boy do you need
an adult no
I am an adult
and okay look here's the thing I think I
know what Toriyama was really going for
with this Gohan section it's the exact
same approach he took for a lot of this
Arc really for him it seems clear that
he wasn't as concerned with the
narrative way of this training section
for Gohan because that comes second to
the primary concern here that being
trying to tell a good joke it seems
clear to me both from reading and his
own notes that he was not so much
concerned with thematic through lines or
narrative tension or any of that really
his primary motivation was funny old Kai
does wacko dance around an annoyed Gohan
being able to cut back and forth between
the dire circumstances on earth and the
auto Ridiculousness of the kaioshin
planet is funny but it is at the cost of
those other elements I think and for
some people they are fine coasting along
through the Buu saga as The Romp that it
is a Victory lap of an arc for Toriyama
pulling every favored move from his
repertoire but I personally cannot get
past how much these gags with Gohan in
particular deflate things despite the
fun gags King Arthur interpretations and
sweet departing moments with Father and
Son all I am left feeling is a sense of
nothingness like a character that has
been built up to for years has been
shelled for the sake of gags only to be
reintroduced as though that Journey he
just went on was a legitimate one
squaring up to superboo following an
heroic moment of last minute rescue it's
almost impossible not to see the
parallels made to Goku At This Moment
Like This was Gohan's scene to steal
requesting to Don his father's ghee
arriving at the last moment following
mystical training now confidently
measuring the depth of the foe that
eagerly awaits him it's a great moment
and one that I can't help but feel
confidence Gohan's time spent on Namek
perfectly unnamek Gohan underwent a
similarly convenient power-up and
through it gained a level of strength
that served him wonderfully as the story
marched onward however despite the
enormous boosts in power surrounded by
the formidable enemy is of that era he
was steal nothing more than a child
fighting against Monsters Frieza in his
second form would Tower over him
sadistically as he all but kills Krillin
before his eyes totally powerless to
help or do anything to stop him and are
not one but two separate occasions his
father would arrive to restore hope to
the worsening circumstances he needed
his father he wasn't ready then but
right here unflinching unblinking and
undeterred Gohan mistaken by Goku by
Piccolo and cheered on by his little
brother looks the living embodiment of
death in his black soulless eyes and
smiles I didn't say this before because
I wanted to wait for this moment but
while I was reading through fatboo's
final moments against his evil skinny
counterpart I had a thought about this
creative choice to alter boost
composition within the narrative
thinking at the time that it perhaps
gave an indication to the sort of
Direction Toriyama one wanted to steer
the story at that very moment during my
analysis of this arc's beginning I drew
attention to the sort of character Gohan
was discovering in the process that he
was very much a reactionary superhero
archetype in every sense of the word I
saw nothing wrong with the designer
approach taken with his character in
fact I thought it was fitting however
the greater story lacked a specific
villain for him to fight against to
react to for the greater good he was
very much a Yin without his Yang a
Spider-Man without his Green Goblin a
Batman without his Joker however while
looking at that vengeful and wrathful
incarnation of Majin Buu manifest and
take rude within the story creating
Super Buu I started to see a villain
that could have potentially drawn out
the very best of Son Gohan it might seem
overly simplistic to suggest that a
villain would have solved all of Gohan's
issues in this Arc and while that is
true it's still a significant issue and
moreover offered a start for the
character in the right story in the
right hands the right villain can
elevate a terrific hero when you're
dealing with the battles of good versus
evil or a hero versus a villain it's
important to design these two sides such
that they complement each other's
strengths a terrific example of this
could be seen between Goku and Frieza in
my review of that material I described
Goku as an Unstoppable Force against
frieza's immovable object revelation of
character is important and with Goku's
fight with Frieza there were several
instances of Revelation when all out of
options Goku threw caution to the wind
to gamble everything on a times 20
Kaioken all the wild when Frieza starts
to feel the pressure he takes it out on
the planet he stands upon when Frieza
was on the cusp of Victory he dragged
everything out teasing Goku and killing
his friends slowly however when Goku
knew he had victory in hand he
immediately quit my point is a villain
does far more than provide a hero a
simple punching bag a great villain
draws out an emphasis sizes the hero's
greatest qualities this is all to say
that in storytelling heroes and villains
oftentimes share similar qualities share
similar traits backstories Etc
intentionally they often are exposed to
or share in the same pain as each other
and beginning from a place of
commonality allows these characters to
feel on some level
intrinsically connected to each other
and the differences that surface between
them arise in the story through the
decisions they ultimately make what they
choose to do about this pain that has
come to Define who they are whether that
be how they themselves deal with
pressure or how they respond to victory
at hand there's a wonderful quote that
succinctly gets to the core of a Great
Hero and a great villain a great villain
might say something like the world hurt
me and so therefore I'm going to hurt it
back whereas a Great Hero like Gohan
might say the world has hurt me but I'm
not going to let it hurt anybody else
in other words Heroes use pain and
villains are used by it and while not a
total one-to-one comparison I think
there's something to the idea that Gohan
has never lost his kindness despite
being faced with the horrors of this
universe only wanting to further help
people all the while this super powered
goo is wrath and evil personified a
sight of boo that's taken control a side
that was created when exposed to the
evils of the universe and indeed
Humanity now resulting in pure wrath
it's such a compelling and Powerful
Story one that speaks not only to
Gohan's character but offers boo 2
something to work with finally Gohan is
in a position he feels natural operating
within and then
Everything Changes regrettably Gohan's
arrival doesn't feel as massive as it
otherwise stood to be simply because in
my view the tone of the story is sort of
all over the place almost as if Toriyama
in this instance was the most unsure
he's been in quite some time in the past
whether it was the case or not the
stories of these arcs have always felt
as though they've been working towards a
Clear Vision Goku vs Vegeta Goku vs
Frieza Gohan vs Cell all the while he
certainly needed to figure out how to
connect the beginnings of these stories
to its endings he had in mind for this
Arc it's very much felt like he's being
totally in the dark himself as to where
this story is even going in a vague
sense especially at this moment in the
story it feels aimless compare this to
when Goku arrived against Napa or
Piccolo arriving against Frieza or
Vegeta arriving against Android 19. to
me Gohan vs superbu is easily one of the
most frustrating because it could have
been so much more and I think
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on your persuasion I think this is where
Toriyama decided how he wanted to end
this story and you can feel that
decision made almost instantly because
Gohan goes from this to this in a
remarkably short amount of time
following the Beatdown Gohan levels
against Super Buu instead of seeing that
fight through to a natural conclusion or
taking a more gohan-centric path
Toriyama as it was reflected in that
quote I shared at the beginning of this
Arc felt as though he wasn't suited to
the role residing himself to a
conclusion led by Goku with Vegeta as a
supporting character and to make this
happen horiyama cuts the Buu fight short
Buu goes off to hide for an hour allows
go tanks the time to recharge and absorb
him and Piccolo leaving Son Gohan alone
against this overpowered monster and
fittingly Buu refers to himself at this
juncture as the most powerful past
present and future seeing as he has now
within him the fighters from all
generations involved in this
counter-offensive it's not at all a bad
plan of attack in fact it's quite
resourceful but it's at this point I
felt as though the narrative started to
come undone and one could easily see
Toriyama the scrambling to set up pieces
for what will be the big finish to this
Arc he will illustrate in pen and in
order for these pieces to get into place
they certainly felt as though Toriyama
was reaching in places creating a very
well downright funny and slightly
depressing atmosphere
what do I mean well number one okay just
gives Goku his remaining life I guess
that's something that can happen now
when Toriyama needs another hero to
return to the battlefield number two
Vegeta then returns to the story
suddenly though this feels a lot more
Justified using an existing mechanic in
Baba number three the patara earrings
are introduced out of nowhere with the
added caveat of their effect being
permanent to counteract the less
cooperation based utilization compared
to the Fusion Dance not a bad inclusion
just extremely last minute making Shin
look like an idiot and obviously
included for the sake of connecting plot
points quickly rather than just to have
fun technically the earrings in
particular were introduced primarily to
separate the fuse Goku and Vegeta from
their movie counterpart Gogeta as
Toriyama has talked about in numerous
interviews but that doesn't change the
outcome not to mention the issue that
would have Arisen had he had Goku and
Vegeta do the Fusion Dance AS originally
planned and finally number four tension
on who looked as though Toriyama was
planning to do something clever with
with him always subtly alluding to his
existence outside of the group now
literally shows up makes one save and
then becomes useless in literally one
second Boo's legs just kick him and he
eats total never to be seen again
in the story outstanding
now listen to them child the voices of
those you failed to save
[Applause]
[Music]
I could feel what he feels
[Applause]
[Music]
ignore that one
but perhaps the aspect of this creative
pivot I have the most issue with is that
this change in Direction flies in the
face of the entire theme of this Arc
fostering the Next Generation where
prior arcs established their themes and
eventually push towards a conclusion
where they would be paid off to
complement that theme this one feels
like it cuts its losses and starts again
an arc which championed the notion of
setting up the Next Generation in all of
its mistakes and wacky Glory now sees
itself communicating another message
entirely and it's the opposite in fact
Goku had left Earth to allow the Next
Generation the opportunity to protect
themselves that was great but then they
fought up so badly that he needed to
take the life force from a literal God
his son sprung from a magical sword
Vegeta needed to be chauffeured from the
grave back to Earth and through the
power of high fashion patara earrings
they need to Pedal out and fuse the
older generation into one super fighter
who screams merchandise more than any
other character in this series resulting
in the moral of the story being don't
trust your children or the Next
Generation them don't forward plan
or anything just improvise yourself and
do everything because your kids are
okay okay maybe I'm being a little
dramatic here this section really gets
me worked up though in truth the
Thematic pivot here is clear in trying
to set up the future generation for
Success the prior generation now must
make one last final return to clean up
the mess they made one final Act of day
saving so that said future generation
can live on and see to fruition their
vision and given this is the final Arc
in the series a series that started as
the sole story of song Goku on some
level it is fair to bring it back to him
as we cross the finish line
unfortunately it's just could we have
come to that conclusion a bit more
gracefully please there are so many ways
we could have arrived at this final
theme the beginning of this Arc even
planted a lot of these seeds sort of
with the Carnage of the tournament and
booze release being solely on the
shoulders of the prior Generations poor
decisions and priorities but once Vegeta
died pretty much every single step we
took led us farther away from those
themes and closer to the youngest
generation cleaning up this mess only
for us to then jump right back in the
final moment save me I'm gonna go insane
foreign
[Music]
all right Vegito despite all my
complaints and narrative confusion from
the previous section once we arrive at
Vegeta's introduction the story finally
resolves down to a very clear goal and
path and unlike the anime which felt
bloated in the manga he erupts into
Super Saiyan right out the gate and gets
to the good stuff now speaking of Vegito
he is a pretty interesting character
mostly because to me at least Vegito
isn't really a character and more so a
result when I look closely at his makeup
Vegito is closer to a moment like Goku
transforming into Super Saiyan for the
first time then he is an actual
character and I say that because the
most interesting thing about him isn't
who he is or what he's like but instead
how he came to be this is a form that
can only come to be through Goku's
willingness to set aside his poison and
work with another Fighter for the
greater good and for Vegeta to do the
same for his loved ones this is a form a
result that can only exist because of
characters are both literally and
figuratively in this exact moment in
time after their shared history
furthermore it's a much more fitting way
to approach the end of this story old
Kai even said it himself quote these two
have the power two of the greatest
Masters in the worlds of the living and
the dead and it doesn't hurt that they
live to outdo each other and that's what
this is that's who Vegito is as a
standalone character he's nothing but as
a character he doesn't need to be
something he's simply a shining and
Powerful symbol of Goku and Vegeta's
respective Journeys having come to a
moment of reconciliation and that's
brilliant and hilariously the existence
of fusion as a concept in Dragon Ball
came about as a joke between Toriyama
and masakazu katsura you are my fan oh
good another Fusion so what are you then
we are a warrior
a combination of Vegeta and girl
girl
huh that was weird why can't we say go
go
are you two are you all right sir we are
talking to ourselves
Vegeta and go whatever you can just call
us vegeto and son go yourself
are we going to school
I will fight you in a minute
there's a lot to love about this section
thematically as a plot be demonstrating
Vegeta and Goku's willingness to throw
their egos and personal preferences to
the side which cause this mess in order
to rescue everyone from inside boo is a
compelling one however this isn't to say
that there aren't any aspects I had
issues with simply put when you start to
think about the infiltration of Boo's
body with Vegito you realize that the
combined contribution of our time spent
with Goten Trunks and Gohan during this
training material all of the fights and
compelling writing all of those chapters
has resulted in little more than a
motivation for Vegito to go inside of
boo now I love the idea of exploring the
insides of him in search of their allies
and the plan with which they escape
through the head is a clever one but
ultimately I'm not a fan of why Goku and
Vegeta remained unfused following this
moment not because I think there is a
thematic shortcoming here or anything
like that but instead because Vegeta
destroying the patara in this moment for
the reasons he's breast doesn't ring
true to the development He's Just
undergone In This Very Arc in the past
Vegeta's below hearty Nature has been
the direct culprit behind so many
negative events taking place in this
story his insecurity and resentful
nature led to cell reaching his perfect
form however it was that very ego that
was cast into the wind along with his
life during his sacrifice an open
acknowledgment that he has changed and
moved past that way of thinking however
despite this he destroys them anyway
knowing that he's still vastly weaker
than Buu currently in making this
decision Vegeta has threatened the fate
of the entire universe for no other
reason than his own personal discomfort
a discomfort that stems from his
distaste of Kakarot a character he will
in mere chapters praise as quote number
one in my mind this would have been a
great moment for them to put aside their
poisons in the name of writing the
wrongs of their past but instead that
very poison creates one last month
monster for them to fight
[Music]
enter kid boo
foreign
but as we approach the finale of this
spectacular story and celebrate All That
Akira Toriyama has brought to the table
over the years it's also time to
celebrate the folks that made this story
move and created an animated adaptation
that introduced a generation of fans all
over the world to Dragon Ball while the
buark story saw a major shake up to its
main players so too did the anime find
itself completely overhauled until this
point Menorah maieda has sat in the
character designer position right from
the very start of the original series
and if you include Dr slump the man is
being the face of Toriyama style
animation for a decade it was time to
shake things up in an anime land
magazine interview my Ada had said he
felt things were starting to stagnate
with him at the helm and so he handed
the Baton over to one of the animators
he had trained up over the years
katsuyoshi nakitsuru and with that he
felt that new life had been brought to
the series and sailed off into the wind
with complete peace of mind a new life
is exactly what was found where Maeda
had struggled with toriyama's Newfound
complex musculature drawing strange
forget plate arms or falling back on
poorly referenced material nakatsuru
immediately elevated the series with
designs filled with impressive line
confidence and a style that felt like a
truly refined and modern take on the
manga but he wasn't alone tariyoshi
yamamura of shindo Productions had been
given design duties for the series as
movies and a chunk of his designs were
already being supplemented with myatas
in the previous Arc this only continued
further with nakatsuru a combination
that created a catalog of material that
meant this new arc was fresh with
excellence in every single way
for many of the sub Studios this
production overhaul seemed to serve as a
real motivator reigniting passion and
encouraging major development for much
of these production segments I've spent
a lot of time poking fun at Yukio
ebisawa's work and accidentally
pronounced his name as ebizawa but shut
up really this was all because his style
was just so bizarrely detached from
Toriyama that it truly verged on Meme
tier at times and well this Arc is
partially his Redemption while there are
absolutely still a big chunk of bizarre
looking scenes from him Studio Lives
episodes largely become a non-issue
toshiyukikano since his very first
episode on the series had been A Cut
Above the Rest and that only got
stronger and stronger as the series
progressed to the point that ebisawa
almost never corrected his work at all
well he clearly paid a lot of attention
to Kano because with this Arc is plain
to see him attempting to mimic his style
and the results aren't half bad at all
with the studio gaining two Newtons Yuko
and Hideki inoue both great in their own
rights and probably not related it
almost certainly seems like evisawa
recognize himself as the weak point and
got the kick up the butt he needed to
ensure his episodes didn't continue to
make him look like a fish out of water I
mean Vegeta's sacrifice is an ebisawa
episode who'd have thought it's such a
recurring theme that it's kind of
inspiring in a way Studio Carpenter was
a studio who joined The Fray in the
previous Arc and you may recall me
mentioning that their supervisor Yuji
hakamada's work was uh not exactly the
best it required some pretty strong
Chief corrections to be brought up to
power and yet in this Arc he ain't
looking too bad at all his work no
longer needs redrawing from scratch and
not only does it often look decent
enough in its own right our newly grown
boy is somehow given some really
important episodes like I don't know the
finale of The Arc what is art is kind of
boxy with strangely pointed noses making
him not exactly my favorite the fact
he's no longer someone to loudly grown
at is a great evolution in my book
all this quick progression and skill
really lends itself to the overall
feeling of this Arc truly being the next
generation of Dragon Ball animation a
studio by the name of K Production
joined the series in this era led by a
man named shingo Ishikawa and while as
we established in the last video
newcomers are subject to Chief
Corrections Ishikawa really didn't need
correcting for very long or even that
intensely after only a few episodes
ishikawa's work Shone brighter than so
many of his peers the guy's work was
seriously polished fiercely aggressive
and best of all his episodes actually
felt super Dynamic thanks to some
incredibly awesome posing he is easy one
of my favorite artists on the show and
responsible for so many amazing moments
and while it was probably a good thing
that Cape production didn't need much
help from the chief supervisors for
there was another Studio that joined The
Fray and apparently they really did need
all the help they could get in spite of
their name Kino Productions was not
exactly Kino in many ways they were kind
of just a Workhorse addition to the
series they popped up for only four
episodes drew a bunch of stuff and then
got completely redrawn I mean the whole
goddamn animation Avengers assembled to
correct their work yamamuro miyahara
nakutsuru and heck even hakamada they
really just seem to exist to create a
bit of breathing room for other sub
Studios and that's kind of it I think
what kind of blows my mind is that
despite the show clearly having the
ability to throw Chief supervisors at
episodes to polish them up this never
ever happened for the people at Studio
last house
uchiyama has long been a bit of a joke
but I often would be willing to overlook
it because he had the likes of notoshi
shida and taichiro Ohara under him well
she is long gone at this point Point as
I noted last video now doing Kick-Ass
insane in-house stuff at toei but now
ohara's not producing anywhere near the
level of work that he used to I mean how
can he it's literally just two people
drawing one entire episode now and
uchiyama is spending so much time
redrawing ohara's crazy looking work and
well fair play to him it might not be
good but it at least turned O'Hara
moderately more Dragon Ball and less
caveman unfortunately it really just
stands out so drastically against a crew
that is basically the strongest it has
ever been the Peaks are as high as ever
but now the valleys have dropped even
lower leading to some real what the
moments from episode to episode a real
Downer given that they have the highest
episode count of any Studio of the show
oh
mercifully it's those highs that I think
genuinely Define this Arc Studio
cockpit's addition to the series in the
cell Arc already produced an all-time
classic of an episode and as the team
led by masunaga head into the bu Arc
things only get stronger and stronger
masunaga's style in the cell Arc was
pretty awesome as is but it didn't quite
adhere to Dragon Ball's design
principles but in this Arc wow his style
completely evolves under these new
designs totally taking on board the
fundamentals of toriyama's style while
still keeping things distinctly unique
all the girls are super extra cutie
waifu tear and then the muscle dudes
have me questioning my sexuality with
the most Next Level shading you've ever
seen and then boom with the fight
against Kid Buu in the kaioshin realm
the cockpit team power up like never
before animating arguably the best
looking episode of the series with
Newfound editions like chisato ikehira
and the now one piece famous masayuki
Sato the episode does not stop moving it
is an assault of crazy frenetic action
with Pokemon Legend misaki iwane
continuing to blow mines with all kinds
of twists and turns and as the episode
heads into its back half it just keeps
going with some of the finest masunaga
Corrections the series has to offer it
is a proper Powerhouse and with it being
the team's final episode of the series
under matsunade's leads they sure went
out with a bang however it's the
director of this episode that I failed
to mention so far who also served as one
of the biggest shakeups this series sees
up until this archdesk initio had been
the series director for all things
Dragon Ball and yet as explored in the
cell video an industry Icon by the name
of shigayasu Yamauchi has been slowly
creeping up in popularity within the
show having directed the first Broly
movie to great success by manyamauchi
was handled full creative control to the
Dragon Ball series taking over as series
director for the boo Arc thankfully
leading the creative charge for the
series as a whole didn't take away from
his ability to direct episodes himself
and while I've already explored his
strengths for powerful emotive direction
through careful Framing and interesting
color work his talent for highly
choreographed action cannot be
overlooked for many tadiyoshi yamamura's
work across the series has redefined
martial arts combat and when you take
his work on this Arc which is already a
complete Cut Above the Rest and then
combine it with yamauchi's action
storyboarding well you get the iconic
Goku vs Majin Vegeta fight that has sat
for many as one of the coolest bouts in
this series
this Arc is legitimately full of some of
the most incredible directors ueda and
kakuchi were two I highlighted last week
but what's kind of nuts is that a guy by
the name of Osama Kasai who directed
like three episodes of the cyan art
before Vanishing Into The Ether who
randomly came back for this Arc and
dropped some real bangers with Studio
sagasha taking on the animation side of
things shimanuki and hisada continued to
trade animation supervisory positions
but their work really under these new
designs is a whole different level of
Polish where other Studio's work is
focused on the slower style of action
that Yamauchi loves the sagasha gang are
all about speed and scale the fights
they animate feel huge and
overwhelming in the best kind of way and
with people like naokitate now fully
evolved and kicking up some spectacular
work on their own with little
supervisory intervention God it's all so
damn good and what's kind of hilarious
is that Kasai then went on to become the
series director for Dragon Ball GT and
well we all know how that turned out
but uh putting all comedy aside I think
what's genuinely nice is that it
highlights how dragon ball sticks with
people the blue arc is a real
culmination of a series whose staff
continue to evolve with its story over
the course of seven years and a Whole
Decade for many of those in senior
positions and that's really what I hopes
to highlight with these production
sections in these reviews Dragon Ball is
a journey for everyone involved this was
a formative show not just for the people
watching but for the ones who helped
bring it to life we've watched animators
and directors go from fresh face newbies
to helming the entire franchise and it's
something that Rings true even 25 years
following the series's conclusion
yamamuro almost exclusively handled
character designs for all things Dragon
Ball until 2018. takeoide became a
teacher at the toei school of animation
and served as Chief supervisor on Dragon
Ball super shimanuki and Tate were both
regular supervisors on that show shida
and Kano have popped up time and again
and nakutsuru continues to work his
magic whenever he's given the
opportunity Dragon Ball has never left
these people and the ones they've
inspired have since joined their ranks
in what is a truly beautiful full circle
Moment The Fan Favorite animator yuya
Takahashi grew up watching the series
and now he's one of dragon Ball's most
beloved animators yamauchi's pupil
tatsuya nagamine not only joined Dragon
Ball super as a series director but then
went on to direct the Dragon Ball super
Broly movie The Very character his
mentor helped bring to life over 20
years prior these are only a few
examples and there are so so many more
while you can throw Fair criticism at
its pacing and inconsistency at times
Dragon Ball's anime is so special it's a
real labor of love and Artistry that has
endured to this day and I'm really glad
to have taken the time to highlight it
here it was what got me and so many
others into this series and it really
deserves this recognition so thank you
for taking the time to enjoy these
little tributes with me and now let's
get back to the very Source material
that inspired it
uh
longer than the both of us right
it almost is dumb got any ideas well
your oldest Brat's still stronger so
where's he on Earth so Dad what and who
did you grab hey are you you kidding me
Kakarot we'll have to grab dende come on
the magic man I get but why that oaf you
know I can hear you I hope you can look
I panicked and I grabbed the Dragon
Balls okay oh so that's how you see me
oh great we have dragon balls and I
always have to live long enough to use
them oh come on I'm sure
I see you for more than your balls your
daughter's a man stealing a
just like her mother
[Music]
the final battle in Dragon Ball despite
what I had to say earlier concerning the
material leading up to and setting this
final fight up I very much enjoy what we
get in the end despite chapters of
pivots and uncertainties we have finally
landed on toriyama's Final focused
vision for an ending and what he does
with it I think works very very well and
more than that is a moment that for many
acts as a symbol of inspiration it's a
battle that holds the very universe and
the balance one that pits the remnants
of the Earth's inhabitants against the
living embodiment of Destruction wrath
and fear like a natural disaster in
physical form of all the incarnations
we've touched on in this Arc Kid Buu
carves out for himself a truly unique
Niche no longer burdened by the ego of
superboo or the naive sentimentality of
fat boo kid boo is what happens when you
strip all Humanity away from this Majin
Beast leaving only death and destruction
behind to animate its unsettling figure
a fitting development for what has
become a fiercely worsening circumstance
forcing the remaining Heroes to grab
what they can that's nearby and flee
before boo without warning destroys the
entire Earth the very home they stood
upon guarding all throughout this story
never before has the planet Goku has
called home received such constant and
horrific treatment and now for the first
time in this series a villain the force
of nature that is Kid Buu has destroyed
what was left of it forcing Goku and
Vegeta along with Mr state nintende to
travel to the world of the kais in the
hopes that it might allow them time to
regroup and formulate a strategy
effectively what we have here is a soft
reset of sorts of everything that's
taken place from Vegeta turning Majin
onwards and honestly this entire section
feels like a natural extension of the
character work following Vegeta
sacrifice Goku and Vegeta are no longer
fighting each other they are working
together to take down Boo and what we
have in Kid Buu is rather purposefully
not so much a character as it is a
symbolic entity weakened in body down to
the approximate strength of Goku despite
what the anime would tell you Kid Buu
represents a couple things firstly he
represents the result of Goku and
Vegeta's selfish actions at the
beginning of the arc the consequence of
the series of dominoes they set up and
secondly perhaps most importantly he
represents a distillation of what Goku
has been searching for since his very
first fight 30 some odd volumes ago a
being of pure strength stamina endurance
and desire to fight Kid Buu is
essentially the result of if Goku went
to the villain Build-A-Bear store the
perfect opponent for Goku to go all out
against and it's clear from the
beginning that despite the dire
circumstances Goku is stoked at this
opportunity choosing to fight one-on-one
like a tournament match as the Elder
kaioshin angrily puts it Goku knows how
important this fight is not only for the
fate of the universe but for himself
personally and as they do begin to fight
it becomes comes even clearer how
perfect these two are for each other
both implementing wildly creative
fighting techniques trading blows
equally and being silly enough to bite
each other never has there been a more
perfect matchup for Sun Goku and looking
back the circumstances of this
one-on-one fight could easily feel
contradictory to the personal growth
that both Saiyans have undergone in this
Arc choosing that very tournament style
approach rather than taking the patara
and ending it all to save the universe
in a Flash but once you dig a bit deeper
you can recognize the subversion being
made here and given the last minute
nature of it all it's actually rather
impressive and resonant this isn't a
decision made by Goku out of selfishness
but instead one where he's trying to
protect Vegeta's feelings all throughout
the cell Arc and well into the Majin
conflict Goku demonstrated an ability to
see right through Vegeta's thinly veiled
bravado ego driven boastful nature and
saw him for who he truly was a man who
didn't know who he was a man that was
lost but in this final battle as a
brilliant subversion Vegeta takes Goku
off guard instead by demonstrating a
rather selfless and humble analysis of
what's taking place an analysis that
feeds into a speech that crescendo's
Vegeta's role in this story it's a
recognition that Goku's always been
stronger than him always being better
than him and more than that he accepts
that right now his greatest
contributions can be offered as a
valuable support to the greatest fighter
under the heavens Kakarot it's an
outstanding moment of character writing
and moving sentimentality from the once
belligerent and now at peace saying
Prince no longer at war with himself and
finally the hero he was always capable
of being and this heroism isn't depicted
through the fight or rather beat down
that Vegeta endures through glorious
conquest of this monster but rather his
ability to eat as much damage as he
possibly can thus allowing Goku the time
to charge his super say in three states
for one last flurry against this pure
evil Boo the entire sequence is made all
the better by achieving something that
is very hard to conjure in the world of
Dragon Ball nowadays the legitimate
chance that Vegeta may die forever
stating that those who die while already
dead disappear forever such that not
even the Dragon Balls can revive them it
massively intensifies the sacrifice
Vegeta is willing to make here and not
to mention ratchets up the tension the
manga's interpretation of this is
fantastic and the anime adds to the
distress of this battle by offering
Vegeta a unique opportunity the chance
to deliver a traditionally egotistical
Vegeta speech but under totally
antithetical circumstances instead of
being on the offensive Vegeta's on the
back but no longer cowering in fear or
scared stiff when confronted by a far
superior fire than he now the same
Prince through accepting himself for who
he is can stand in front of death
incarnate taunting and grinning the
clock down until his final breath facing
Oblivion with more bravery than any I've
seen in this series and man it's some of
my absolutely favorite material to come
from Vegeta in the anime however despite
stalling for more than enough time Goku
still hasn't rejoined the battle
something is clearly very wrong
at this juncture with Vegeta after being
pummeled into the dirt and Goku now
weaker than ever surprisingly the
situation hasn't been more dire there's
no hero to save the day Vegeta can't
stop him and Goku's Super Saiyan 3 isn't
viable in a living host and presently
the only thing holding back Boo from
killing Mr Satan now is the residual fat
boo within him and what's more is
Kid Buu knows it and spits him out
[Applause]
[Music]
you should have saved your son no I
think I have a plan to beat boo was it
saving your son listen
I'm gonna use the Spirit Bomb no why
Give Me One Reason I'll give you three
you used it on me didn't work you used
it on Frieza didn't work and you didn't
even bother using it on Cell like yeah
because I knew it wouldn't work but it
will listen though
fine but if this doesn't work I will
kill you if this doesn't work boo will
kill you and I will drag you to hell
with me feel okay so fat boot can hold
off Kid Buu for a short period of time
time to formulate a plan and honestly
despite having some arguable
contrivances I kind of love the picture
this plan paints for us watching and
reading along it feels very much like
the culmination of everything Goku's
been through the battles the friendships
the ups and the Downs this next section
is really rather beautiful with their
backs up against the wall Goku and Allah
as to what they can do next and the time
they have ticking by Vegeta formulates a
strategy
the Genki Dharma Kid Buu is a rather
interesting variation of enemy like I
mentioned where all the enemies of
dragon Ball's past offer their own
Larger than Life personalities defining
their own arcs this variation of boo
that Toriyama has chosen to land on for
his big finale is less of a character
insofar as it's not his personal
decisions that makes him interesting but
instead it's what he offers the heroes
of this tale that makes him compelling
he's horrifically dangerous but calling
him evil almost seems to limiting in the
same way we wouldn't call a hurricane
evil it's difficult to Simply label Kid
Buu as such he's a living manifestation
of Wrath brought about by the corruption
inhumanity of others and by being such
unlike Frieza Vegeta Piccolo Sal and all
the other villains of dragon Ball's past
he doesn't demand your attention instead
he simply acts dispassionately when
Super Buu was born after consuming the
Kinder factfu Toriyama wrote something
in his narration that stuck with me he
said quote alas sweetness stands little
chance against concentrated Wrath
and this line stuck with me because this
scene feels like toriyama's answer to
that very sentiment he expressed as Goku
throws his hands into the air almost
symbolic of his surrender to the present
dire circumstances he also throws into
motion a certain Poetic Justice a
technique which represents kindness
sweetness and Purity an attack made
possible thanks to those that love and
support Goku an attack that can only
work against beings with evil in their
heart and it seems like no other
creature introduced in Dragon Ball's
long and winding history is more
befitting of being the target of this
righteous move than the Monstrous Kid
Buu however before that part takes place
they need the requisite energy
whoa
[Applause]
okay so this plan is not without its
contrivances so it's brought to Goku's
attention that the namekians not only
have the Dragon Balls gathered but have
also updated paronga's powers to do
exactly what Vegeta needs them to do in
order to make good on the Genki dama he
wants to resurrect all the good people
who died during this arcs material a
virtuous wish sure but it's made on the
back of unnecessary contrivances boy
aren't we lucky that this is now
possible on the namekian dragon balls
but the sentiment Vegeta expresses as
the inspiration behind this plan is
perfectly fitting for a final fight such
as this suggesting that Goku has saved
the Earth enough and that Justice once
they should be given the chance to try
and save themselves I love this creative
decision it takes Goku's approach in
wanting to give the younger generation a
fair shot at dealing with Buu and offers
that same opportunity to the people they
have tried to save over the years and
this plan is all coming from Vegeta it's
such a great idea that offers the Vegeta
character a fantastic platform to
demonstrate how he's changed from a
foreign entity wishing to destroy and
enslave the world to one that now can
call it home it also however offers him
a chance to show that he still has that
short temper and again this is a great
creative Choice using his character to
propel the conflict further in order to
create tension Vegeta's plan might have
been a good one but because of who he is
it doesn't work and now suddenly our one
and only chance has hit a significant
roadblock and what's more is fat boo
can't fight anymore
there's a wonderful thing that happens
in storytelling when you combine
expectation and Rising tension you start
to relate to the present circumstances
of the story no matter how different
their literal components might be to
your own desperate to turn the tide in
their favor to save Vegeta to save the
Earth to save the universe against this
seemingly Unstoppable wave of negativity
and torment that is Majin Buu Goku
continues to hang on and amidst the
chaos asks for help and the most
beautiful part of it all is warm and
familiar voices answer his plea
foreign
[Music]
I was just a little kid a little kid
that like many others my age suffered
from bullying and a sense of isolation a
sense of desperation and through
watching this scene unfold before my
eyes as the allies and faces from Goku's
travels unite together to offer help
when all hope had been lost for the
first time in my life I experienced
chills it told me that no matter how bad
things get no matter how terrible the
threat or how hopeless things might seem
right now if you keep pushing forward
and ask for help in your darkest moments
there's always a chance someone out
there can help you and help can reside
in the most unlikely of places
[Music]
[Applause]
underestimated you Mr Satan
[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Satan the conniving insecure liar
that propped up during the South Saga
the man that represented everything that
Goku and Piccolo weren't interested in
in modern martial arts during this
material has not only demonstrated that
he can change transforming into an
altruistic hero saving Vegeta but in a
showcase as of lifting as it is
hilarious proves that all the fame he
gainerd can in fact be used for good and
in this case it quite literally saved
the universe granting the Genki dama the
strength necessary to wipe this poison
from the universe but it's still not
enough this entire battle has been a
struggle and a war all wrapped up into a
stunningly exciting package and to tell
you the truth at this point I was at a
total loss as to how they could turn
this all around at every turn Kid Buu
has proven to be capable of taking
everything head-on and belt back from it
like some sort of magical deranged
bubblegum monster careful strategy
complicated plans the support of
billions it still isn't enough and
that's when it happens the perfect wish
is made throughout this series Goku and
his friends have made increasingly
complicated wishes on two sets of dragon
balls and impressive as it was to see
these clever plans unfold before our
eyes in this moment when expecting a
complicated solution to a seemingly
impossible problem we're given possibly
the most simple wish ever made in this
series restore Goku to full power and as
Boo staggers and struggles to hold back
the combined effort of billions Goku
pauses looks down and quietly says
you fought hard all by yourself I hope
you get reincarnated as a good guy so I
can fight you one-on-one I'll be
training and waiting and with that and
with one final push kid boo is defeated
come on
[Music]
the threat of boo is no more man what a
culmination and payoff of everything
more than any other part of the story
this finish had all hands on deck and
was coated with callbacks to Dragon
Ball's past even small moments like
dende immediately agreeing to heal
Vegeta or Vegeta acquiescing to Goku's
request to spare fat boo a request he
would never have agreed to before
guys I need more energy someone talk to
him I'm busy bombing yeah yeah I've got
it oh okay
people of Earth
what the put down your trash food
turn off your television and get on
with it matter for what's in your
meaningless little insignificant
worthless human lives you know what
screw this I'm taking my energy back
yeah this guy
it's either stop the cheating you're
making it worse don't you burp me stop
doing it all wrong let me take a swing
at this you think you can give a better
speech than royalty oh please I've been
calling these suckers for years oh wait
they didn't hear that did they ah no
good gotta keep that gas lit all right
my time
people lover wait is that Mr Satan
Hale
[Applause]
I swear to God I'd let that planet burn
if it wasn't where I kept all my stuff
what about your wife and kids I said my
stuff hey problem is still not enough
hey you should probably you know oh all
right but only one hand
touching celebrations and reunitings are
had activity that would serve as a
perfectly cheerful note to end any other
story
but Akira Toriyama isn't just any other
author Ten Years Later
thank you
foreign
and winding road over the last 40 or so
years it's possessed more than its fair
share of endings Canon or otherwise for
many Dragon Ball GT's conclusion is a
favorite tying everything we love about
this series and its characters up in a
beautifully nostalgic bomb of emotion
and celebration Dragon Ball super even
offered an ending that satisfied many at
the time and while the original ending
has its detractors out there for me this
is the most thematically appropriate
ending out of all the ones we have while
Dragon Ball GT's ending is justifiably
beloved in its own right I'd argue it's
an ending that doesn't feel as quote
Dragon Ball as what this original
version offered following this time skip
unlike many other stories with their own
Rich endings this feels almost
disarmingly familiar in the same vein of
fostering the Next Generation were
reintroduced to everyone and get to see
the directions they're all eager to
pursue we see where Gohan's interests
are now how Goten and Trunks have
changed and developed their own
individual personalities what pan is
like it all of her adorable Scrappy
Splendor it's all about defining that
next generation
oh my it's been so long 10 years right
what are you talking about I saw you
barely over a year ago because of that
black Frieza nonsense oh right remember
when I was black that was weird I dyed
my hair for a bit and I stopped looking
exactly like my dad is that before or
after we met Broly which one the good
one oh after huh whatever happened to
beerus I think he's napping again and
then there was cheering remember
cheering
so did you guys ever beat Frieza
probably let's take Pandora First World
Tournament before GT will enter
[Applause]
and then everything changes from
familiar to unfamiliar the story hyper
focuses on Goku and the attention he has
on this little unknown fighter in the
tournament called Ube whom we don't know
anything about beyond the broad Strokes
of what Goku has already offered us this
is the part people have taken issue with
and to a certain extent I can understand
why as an ending it doesn't feel
definitive or final in the slightest in
fact it almost feels unceremoniously
sudden if not downright abrupt but I
think that's the entire point of this
ending
Dragon Ball and the story of Goku is one
that will live on long after we close
this final page it's
your we've been good chance to follow
along with one that evolves as Goku and
his friends Forge their own paths
forward
for me as if to poetically bookend this
series with the same philosophical
Outlook that helped to establish Goku in
this story this ending tells us that in
the same way we should always anticipate
someone stronger around the next corner
so too will there always be a new and
rapturing magical and exciting Dragon
Ball story for Goku and his friends to
explore that while it is true that the
end of Z isn't a definitive conclusion
it is an ending that reassures us that
Dragon Ball will always be there an
endless wonderful Adventure that will
continue far beyond the final page in
all of our Collective imaginations and I
think that's beautiful
so you're saying you're only here
because your family is poor and you need
the money yes I spent all the remaining
money on a plane ticket here please let
me win or we are literally going to die
well what I'm hearing is I need to
abandon my life at home and spend the
next couple of years training you how to
punch well good my mother has not eaten
in days Obama already on it they will
never know hardship again man I'm glad
all the people with money use it for
good
Gohan chichi I know this is probably
tough to hear but oh no it's cool have
fun really of course we've had you home
for a decade now if anything a little
much well you heard him come on boo boob
boob
[Music]
despite the amount of work having gone
into this it's important to me that
folks don't look at this as some sort of
definitive review of the series you
might recall the numerous multi-language
visual montages Within These videos and
of all the hours worth of analysis those
montages are for me stronger than any
line I've written for me they show the
scope of what Dragon Ball means across
the world that it's not just a story
that means one thing to one person but a
far-reaching epic Crossing cultures
language barriers and indeed Generations
every single one of you out there has a
unique point of view and experience with
this tale that only you can breathe life
into I truly believe great works of art
and Beauty are in the eyes of their
beholders and highlighting that fact was
at the heart of the series you know it's
funny I've been covering Dragon Ball
animation for about a decade at this
point I first started on a tiny web
forum and then I covered Dragon Ball
super on YouTube which maybe some of you
watched but what's kind of sick is that
it's taken me all around the world and
I've been able to meet a load of amazing
people throughout that time one of those
people being Mark I did do a little bit
of Dragon Ball Z coverage here and there
back in the day but I was mostly focused
on super I never got the chance to tell
C's story in the way that I've been able
to in this series and it might not be a
super in-depth Deep dive that covers
absolutely everyone involved but I hope
you at least got the sense that Dragon
Ball's production kinda has its own
special story alongside the actual story
of Dragon Ball you know it's a series
that means so much to everyone attached
to it and who that includes just keeps
growing with every new show shintana
yukubota Takahashi there are so many new
people attached to this show I really
love that stuff and I really hope that
came through in my segments so I just
want to say thank you so much for
watching and of course thank you so much
to the team for putting such an
incredible series together so many hours
of work across these past few weeks but
more than anything I really hope you
guys you guys walk away from this with a
feeling of just why this series means so
much to so many
and over these past few months working
together with Mark and AJ to put
together these colossal scripts one
thing has become even more clear to me
even if I already knew it from the
beginning
that Dragon Ball despite its unassuming
nature despite its reputation for
Simplicity Dragon Ball is Art it is a
crowning achievement in the world of
fiction and its anime has been a host to
a plethora of generational talent in
terms of Music animation Direction The
Works Dragon Ball touches every corner
of the planet and that is for good
reason I hope throughout this series we
have been able to put into words even a
fraction of that magic
like many of these talented people I got
to work with I too grew up with this
magical series being able to collaborate
as a team not only gave me the
opportunity to relive the story that
brought so much joy and happiness to
many people around the world but it also
made me remember what caused me to fall
in love with this series as well despite
the many turns and twists this Series
has and continues to make over the years
I still love it as much as I did as a
kid and despite me working on the team
for only a few months now I'm truly
honored that I was able to collaborate
with Mark editor AJ Tyson Trev and the
wonderful people over at Team 4 star to
create something like this something
that allowed us to truly celebrate this
wonderful Musical Adventure that we all
know and love is Dragon Ball
[Music]
thanks for your support and I hope you
had fun with the whole series okay
that's all the time I've got I gotta get
back to playing Animal Crossing new Leaf
on my Nintendo 3DS
once again I hope you all enjoyed
reliving this story with us if you'd
like to support this channel feel free
to subscribe right here on YouTube for
more in-depth videos or perhaps consider
joining our patreon where we have even
more goodies and perks but until then
this has been my team I've been Mark
Fitzpatrick and we thank you so much for
watching
[Music]
um
foreign